hey what's going on everybody i'm carl i
am the presenter for this session and uh
i'm the author of the book serverless
machine learning in action
this is what this session is actually
going to be about and in particular i'll
focus on
a particular aspect of machine learning
which is commonly used in deep learning
and artificial neural networks so this
session is going to be about what's
known as automatic differentiation
uh just a little bit in terms of my
background uh if you're interested i
encourage you just to google my name uh
search for carl azub you'll find a lot
of the information about what i've done
uh but
i worked as a software engineer
uh data scientist technology executive
for about 19 years at this point
i work primarily at google and ibm
and
a lot of what i'm going to share with
you today is really based on my
experience with ml
so
if you're interested
there's some links there on the slide if
you want to reach out feel free to shoot
me an email that's the best email to
contact me if you prefer more of an
anonymous way of reaching out that's my
twitter handle right there uh but that's
pretty much it about me i want to make
this session all about this book that
you're seeing there on the right hand
side
uh so the book is about serverless so is
it really about doing machine learning
about without servers no
so serverless here means uh
without using servers during your
machine learning development experience
so if you're a machine learning
practitioner if you're a data scientist
if you are
a machine learning engineer you probably
have been in a situation where you had
to put your machine learning system
up on a public cloud like aws gcp azure
and then uh you were stuck
spending a lot of time uh figuring out
different services in public cloud
figuring out how to
maybe get something like spark up and
running in cloud properly configured so
uh you know it takes quite a bit of
effort
so this book is all about minimizing all
this overhead all of this operations uh
busy work
for a machine learning practitioner and
instead helping you stay productive and
helping you work on what you do best
which is ml
so
obviously in this short session which is
going to be
just probably about 90 minutes or so
we're not going to be able to cover
everything so if you're interested in
the in the scope uh just navigate to
that bitly link
uh and if you want to check out the
whole book uh you can use the discount
code on the bottom right
so that's the best way to find out
what's
what's
in the book in the entirety but in this
session i'm gonna focus on this uh
pytorch automatic differentiation
feature known as autograph
so if you have done machine learning
before today you may have heard about
pytorch so pytorch at this point uh is
what i think is the leading machine
learning framework for doing uh neural
networks
you may have heard of tensorflow well at
this point pi torch is leading by many
indicators and pytorch is using is used
for deep learning in
companies like tesla so for example
they're using pytorch
for the tesla
automated driving capability and pytorch
is even used for research so top
research organizations like open ai are
using pytorch to create cutting edge
language models so a very very powerful
framework uh i've used tensorflow in the
past i switched over to pytorch and i'm
not looking back
now there's a specific feature within
pytorch known as autograph
and autograd is all about providing this
ability which is critical for neural
networks to back propagate gradients so
what does that mean well this is what
the session is all about i'll teach you
what that means exactly
from first principles and in fact uh by
the end of the session you'll be able to
implement
automatic differentiation using basic
python
on your own in fact i'll provide you
with a notebook on how you can do that
uh so that's what the session is all
about uh let me go ahead and get started
because we're about five minutes into
the intros
and
let me fire up my collab environment so
if you've never seen this before which i
doubt because most of you i think are
python developers
this is the uh jupiter notebook
environment available available from
google and i'm pulling up an existing
notebook
that actually i linked to in the
running chevron
in the lower third so if you want to
follow along feel free to open up that
link there are two notebooks there
there's the exercise notebook
which i copied into my environment
and that's what you're seeing on the
screen
but in addition to that there's also a
solution notebook with all the code
already in there so what i'm going to do
is just live code for this exercise
notebook
explaining as i'm going along with
everything uh everything that i'm doing
so uh
just to give you a little bit of a
background in terms of what's going to
happen in this notebook i'll introduce
very quickly this core data structure
known as a tensor so it's core to deep
learning uh and it's very fundamental to
many areas of machine learning so i'll
explain quickly what is a tensor
and fundamentally it's a
multi-dimensional array but in this
session we'll stick primarily to two
types of tensors known as scalars think
of them as individual values and arrays
or think of them as python lists if you
prefer so i'll show you how you can use
pi torch to do basic operations on
tensors and
use this pi torch autograph framework
for linear regression
now
i've talked to many machine learning
practitioners who've seen this pytorch
auto grad framework
and they just
use it as is so they don't really
understand what's going on behind the
scenes and
you know it can be tough to to figure
out how to use it appropriately
and figure out all the details of the
framework so what i'm going to do is
show you how you can solve a very
fundamental
machine learning problem data science
problem which is linear regression using
pytorch i'll explain what are the common
questions that come up
when people try to use this automatic
differentiator
feature for linear regression for other
models and then i'll
dive into the behind of the sea behind
the scenes picture and explain how you
can actually implement key features of
automatic differentiation uh using
python yourself
so once we do that i'll be able to
explain some of the design principles
behind by torch uh help you understand
why auto gradient this auto gradient
auto div framework works the way it does
and by the end of the session you'll be
a lot more comfortable understanding how
to use this
back propagation automatic
differentiation feature from pytorch in
your own code
now in the chat i'm getting a request to
get linked to the notebook let me do the
following i'll actually go in and type
in the
bitly link to the notebook into the chat
and maybe if somebody can help me out
and
type in some of those other links into
the chat as well that'd be awesome
because the links are actually running
in that lower third
on the bottom of the screen
all right so that's uh uh that's what
we're gonna do uh this should take us
another uh hour and 20 minutes or so so
if you're interested feel free to join
in and let's uh let's get started
so what i have here right now is just a
bunch of steps to go ahead and import
some of the prerequisite libraries
if you've ever done any kind of data
science or machine learning in python
before today
a lot of this should look familiar but
fundamentally
here's what i'm doing i'm importing the
pytorch library so i already have it
pre-installed here and i'm aliasing it
spt so you may have seen some people use
alias
torch instead but pt
is easier on my fingers when i type it
so that's what i'll stick to
and
these next two lines two and three are
basically importing a graphing library
i'll use it very briefly just to
illustrate the problem
uh but we're not going to do a lot of
visualization it'll basically help us
generate scatter graphs and some basic
line plots
so this line 4 is actually setting the
figure size so we can get
uh easy to read figure pt dot manual see
so this is actually a pi torch feature
where you specify the
seed for this pseudo-random number
generator so if if you generated
pseudorandom numbers in the past
should be familiar and then finally pt
dot uh
uh this dunder method version
reports that i'm using uh pytorch
version 151 and this is the cuda enabled
version so this means that you can
actually accelerate by torch
using gpus
now in this session i'm not going to be
using gpus but
all the concepts that you learn here
today apply to
gpus as well
so let's recap this idea of a tensor so
if you've ever used arrays and arrays of
arrays to represent the matrix you're
like well on your way to understanding
tensors so tensor is what's known as a
multi-dimensional array or it's a
general point of view and what is an
array if you use the nd arrays and
numpys
in numpy this is uh pretty much the same
thing with a few exceptions so i'm not
talking about tensors that exist in
physics so tensors in uh
some of the more
abstract parts of mathematics this is
tensor for deep learning and it's a
multi-dimensional array so when you have
this kind of a multi-dimensional array
the key description of this array is the
number of indices that you need to
actually access the value in a tensor
so let's actually break this down and
figure out what's going on well the most
obvious kind of a tensor is essentially
a list or an array and this is what's
known as a one-dimensional or rank one
tensor for sure so what this means is
that you only need a single index value
to pull out some values stored inside of
this array so it might be kind of a
weird way of looking at
python lists for you
but thinking keep in mind that you just
need a single index value to pull out of
a value from this list data structure so
that's rank one tensor and then if
you've ever built matrices where you
have arrays of arrays right you can have
uh one
set of um
arrays for the rows and then the columns
are basically represented as arrays of
arrays well you need two indices to pull
out a value from that kind of a data
structure which means you have rank two
or two dimensional tensor and that's
what we call matrix and the cool thing
about tensors and this is what we'll do
in this session as well is that you can
go in the other direction so you can
imagine having a rank zero tensor and if
you think about it for a second
basically it means you don't need any
indices at all to get a value out of a
tensor so what kind of a data structure
is that
obviously that's just a variable right
what kind of a data structure does not
require an index in a programming
language just variable or as we'll call
it in this session a scalar so scalar is
uh
is a term that comes in from mathematics
and the cool thing about tensors and if
you do advanced deep learning you
actually do this in practice you can
actually go on further so you can go
into rank free tensors and if you've
ever uh stored graphical images um
think like color images right you can
have a color images that has
the channel dimension so it has
something like red green blue and alpha
channel for opacity so that would be an
example of this dimension like think of
it as a depth of this rank 3 tensor so
that's the channel dimension and then
the image itself is actually stored as a
matrix as a matrix of x y values of
different pixel intensity so intensity
of the red pixel intensity of the green
pixel and so forth so it's a it's a
highly general
data structure data container if you
want to think of it that way
and it's very useful in deep learning
the last thing i want to mention about
tensors and this is important if you're
actually planning to use tensors uh as a
machine learning practitioner
is that
along every dimension
you have the constant number of elements
so this means that for example if you
have a rank two tensor
uh you must have the same number of
elements along every row so it's not
like you can have 50 elements in the
first row and then 25 in the second row
doesn't work that way it's always the
constant number of elements along every
dimension
so in a short that's that's the tensor
if you want to learn more about them uh
check out the book
so let's actually switch over to live
coding i'll do a quick check on the
chat messages looks like uh some of you
got the links which is awesome so let's
actually go ahead and play around with
some tensors and what i'll do here is
that to initialize this x as a tensor
array
uh i'll use the pi torch apis and in
particular i'll use this pi torch api
called linspace so if you've ever used
numpy linspace hey it's exactly the same
thing
and what i'll do is that i'll initialize
it with 50 elements uh between negative
five and five and actually let's take a
look at these elements
so here's what it looks like i know it
says tensor if you use numpy it says
array but this is what's known as a
one-dimensional rank one tensor right
you only need a single index to fetch a
value like this
okay so that's x
and um if you have some machine learning
background the idea with all these
values that we just generated
is to set up a linear regression model
which means that we need some data
that let's say exists in two dimensions
so we'll have a linear regression model
in two dimensions which means that we
have one dimension for the features
which is going to be uppercase x and
then you have y
and y we're going to define as 2 times x
if you're wondering about the period
that means that i want to use the
floating point number value and uh here
in order to generate some noise
i'll use the built-in pi torch function
called rand n which is basically using
gaussian distribution
and uh for the size of this rand then
i'll create this uh
tensor of noise of the same size as x
meaning that i'll take every uh value
from x right so that's our input tensor
i'll double it and then to every value
i'll add some of this gaussian noise so
if you remember the shape of the uh that
bell shaped standard normal curve this
is the kind of noise that i'm adding
there and this is why these values are
not exactly double what they are of x so
in fact what i'm going to do is i'm
going to go ahead and plot this as a
scatter plot so let's plot it this way
and in fact what i'll do alongside of
that is that i'll plot x
and twice x without
noise so you can actually see what this
diagram should look like in fact let's
change this a little bit let's change
this to a plot
and now you can see that
the dots that are in the x and y values
right so along the horizontal axis we
have the x and the y represents the
vertical axis so the blue dots
are the data points that we just created
and the red line is just the plot of
twice of x right without the noise so
why do this right obviously you can do
this in in any language this is not too
interesting so let's
actually transition over into using pi
torch and i'll show you how you can
solve this classical linear regression
problem
using the uh gradient descent algorithm
which is used to train uh neural
networks essentially we're going to
transition here from regular data
science into some aspects of machine
learning and deep learning so here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to start
introducing some of these features of
the pytorch autograd library and to do
that i'll create
a model parameter so why do we have this
model parameter the problem that i want
to solve is essentially estimating the
slope of this red line okay
and the way that i'm going to estimate
it is by using the data using these blue
dots okay so i'm going to feed in the
blue dots into my linear regression
solver right or estimator which is going
to use gradient descent and i'm going to
try to recover the shape of this trend
between the uh the values the uppercase
x and the y so ideally i should be able
to recover this value of the slope of
the strand line that you're looking at
and the way that we're going to do this
is a traditional way that we
use in machine learning which is to
build a model and our model in this case
is going to be super simple just one
single
parameter we're going to call it w
and i'm going to initialize it using
what's known as a torch empty method i'm
just going to say hey give me a single
scalar so here this is the size
and if you take a look at the resulting
tensor it's a scalar now if you call
pt.empty right it gives you some value
some initialized value in this case we
got lucky it's pretty close to a zero
but i want to be more certain so what
i'd like to do is actually take this w
and initialize it using a random value
and for that i'll use uh pt
actually let's use this initialization
function
called uniform so if you've ever seen
this flat uniform distribution
from negative one to one
that's exactly what i'm using so let me
parse this out this means go ahead and
use the uniform distribution from
negative one to one to initialize the
value of the model model parameter w
and uh shove the result into
uh w actually let's do it this way make
things easier
there we go
so now uh it will complain about the
deprecation uh because i'm
using an older uniform
initialization
but now you can see that the value that
we initialize the model to
is this random value
from the range of negative one to one
and if you're wondering about the
pseudorandom values basically means that
any value in this range is equally
likely that's what having a uniform
distribution means
okay so that's w and
if you're wondering if you're more of an
expert in deep learning
you're wondering why i'm not using
better initialization like xavier or
gaming initialization it's because um
uh this is just a single parameter i
just don't have
uh any
additional inputs or outputs for this
parameter to use more complex
initializations
now the whole point of having this w
value
is that now i can actually
use this to help me make guesses
based on the data so what does it mean
to make guesses well in machine learning
we have this concept of a forward
function which makes guesses about the
data
using the model so our model is super
simple so let's
let's go ahead and explain how we're
going to make guesses about what is the
predicted value of y so we're going to
say that this model is going to generate
predictions of y
simply by taking x and multiplying that
by w
and then we'll return the
predictions
this is all that this model is going to
do so we take the input data remember
these are horizontal
axis values along the x-axis
multiply them by a single model
parameter that generates some
predictions and then we return those
predictions so just if you wanted to see
what the example would look like
uh it would be forward of x then w
and here are predictions well obviously
these are predicted these predictions
are terrible right if you think about
the original values that we generated
here
and actually see them
for example the first value for y
would say is the right value it's
negative eight
uh it's
way off the prediction
but that's the whole idea behind machine
learning right we have a way to model
data we make an initial guess and then
we improve that guess over time
so that's the approach that we're going
to take here
so let's go ahead and do that and then
the question is how do we estimate how
well we're doing with guessing well in
order to do that we need to be able to
define what's known as a loss function
or if you per cost function so let's
call it msc for mean squared error
and
this is going to measure how well we're
predicting and the way that it's going
to measure is that first it'll estimate
the error and the error is simply going
to be the difference between the
predicted and the
actual values
and then what we're going to return is
the
mean
of the squared differences so mean
errors so let's go ahead and return p t
dot mean
uh error
squared right so
exponentiation in python and we're
returning the mean squared so this means
that we can actually do things like uh
msc
take the actual values right from the
from our data set
and then compare that to the predictions
of the model based on the
input data and the model that we're
using and return
our error and that's it so this is
actually the mean squared error
based on the current versions of the
model
okay
so that's uh that's where we are now
let's actually go ahead and start using
gradient descent
so everything that you've seen so far is
just basic um
basic definition from machine learning
the different ways of solving this
problem how do you actually minimize
loss right how do you reduce the loss of
this uh function by changing w there are
different techniques for solving that
but the technique that we're going to
use is gradient descent because it makes
use of the pi torch
autodiv feature and
it's a very fundamental algorithm that
you need to know if you ever want to get
into
neural networks
now in my implementation of gradient
descent
i'm going to use this definition of
epochs
and learning rate so these are constants
so
if you're wondering how i got them the
answer is
the simple answer is trial and error the
more sophisticated answer is
hyperprimary tuning so if you're
interested happy to talk later about
hyperprimary tuning but for the time
being let's just say that these
constants can be used to solve the
problem but what we really care about is
solving the problem not necessarily
these constants so the way that gradient
descent is going to work is that we take
a bunch of gradient descent steps so
what does this mean let's actually do
actually arrange epochs let's do these
epochs of gradient descent
and here epoc means that we are actually
iterating for the entire data set
a training data set to improve our model
to create our model
all right so let's go ahead and
uh implement it the first thing that we
need to do is figure out our predictions
and measure the loss on those
predictions so what are our predictions
we're going to call them ypres and
remember that we do a forward method we
take x uh w is our model right a simple
simple model is just one parameter so
these are predictions and our loss is
what we define using mean squared error
as the difference between the actual
values and the predictions so that's it
right so that's our loss
nothing
uh nothing too complex so far what makes
this different is that notice that now
we're actually doing this repeatedly in
the past i showed you that
you can compute these guesses right
guesses for y or predictions for y
uh just one at a time but what we're
going to do now is do these in epochs
right in these complete passes over the
data set so in order to do that in
context of gradient descent
here you need to start using something
that actually has to do with the uh
pytorch auto diff library the first
thing that you need to do is make sure
that w
is actually initialized with gradients
so this is the first uh kind of a
feature that i need to add here which
you may
say feels a little bit magical so
let me go ahead and change this in the
code and then i'll explain what happens
notice that now when i'm creating this
sensor let me go ahead and initialize it
it has this feature that says requires
grad equals true
now i'm going to give you an
introduction answer as to why i'm doing
this and then i'll do a deeper dive
behind autodiv and actually explain in
code
how you can actually implement this grad
on your own at a very very high level
what this means is that if you have a
tensor like in this case it's a simple
rank zero a scalar tensor
requires grad equals true
ensures that you can actually compute
gradients or derivatives in this case
uh for the values of this tensor
so if you're not sure about the
difference between derivatives and
gradients i'm sure you know about
derivatives from uh college but
gradients think of gradients as
multi-dimensional derivatives so if you
compute derivatives across more than one
variable that's basically called a
gradient
so this means that we can compute
gradients for this value of the tensor
so
if you're feeling unsatisfied from this
explanation
uh don't be surprised because the first
time i saw that i wasn't very happy with
that explanation either this is what
this session is all about teaching you
what does this actually mean and how do
you actually take advantage of this
okay so that's the first change that
we've made right we redefined w to
actually have this uh gradient feature
so what this means is that now that you
have this gradient feature the first
thing you need to do
is uh what's known as zero out this
gradient
now this is the step that actually
seems most magical to users of pytorch
uh and probably one of the most frequent
questions that i get
is um uh this
zeroing out of the gradients uh do i
need to do this
uh here can i put the zeroing out of the
gradients here
can it happen after backward or before
backward
uh the short answer is
hang on we'll dive deep dive a little
bit deeper to explain what this gradient
thing is why do you need to zero it out
and then alex you'll be able to figure
out on your own where exactly it needs
to happen in the implementation
of your gradient descent
now the second step which is lost it
backward
uh at a very high level again this
introductory answer this is actually
doing back propagation of mean squared
error
back to this parameter back to the model
parameter so it's figuring out
how to change what is the gradient of w
with respect to the loss or in other
words how do the changes of the w
parameter impact the changes or in the
loss because remember the idea is to
minimize this loss
minimizing the loss means
improving the predictions that you're
making with this very very simple model
so these are your predictions this
computes the loss the difference between
the predictions and the actual values
and the idea is to improve on the loss
so how do you do that if you've done
gradient descent before today you know
that the approach is to take your model
parameter and you can actually change
the data in other words that value in
the tensor
uh and reduce it by the learning rate
times
w graph
so that's that's all
and in fact if i go in and run this
assuming i didn't make any bugs while i
was chatting
yeah so you can see that um it this
worked right so it ran for 100 epochs
which means 100 passes for this entire
data set of 50 points
and then at every step it was actually
changing the original value of the
tensor remember we started out with the
value that was about 0.8
and now it's basically two right that's
the value that we use to generate the uh
the data set
so if this feels a little bit magical to
you
um i encourage you to go to uh machine
learning 101 or if you're interested in
the appendix of my book i do an
explanation of the intuition behind
gradient descent
but conceptually this should make sense
right
we're making guesses about w
we're figuring out how would changing w
uh improve your predictions or in other
words minimize loss and we're changing w
value
in the direction
to improve the prediction
so the w grad is basically the kind of a
change that you can make to w to improve
the predictions
and
if you've ever done linear algebra
you may have seen this kind of a
solution which is the analytical
solution to
linear regression in fact in pi torch of
course what you can do is figure this
out on your own so
x dot t is basically the linear algebra
or
operation of matrix transpose so if i do
this it's essentially this left part in
the parentheses
and then i need to raise that to the
negative first power so let's do
inversion of this stuff
so here's the
here's what i get
if i compute the this this first part of
the analytical solution to the linear
regression problem and then i also need
to multiply that by x transpose
matrix multiply y
so that's the right hand side of this
problem and now what i can do is
multiply them together now notice that
in this case i'm dealing with scalars so
these are not matrices anymore so i
cannot use
matrix multiplication which is the add
sign to multiply these two i have to use
just a regular multiplication but
basically if i apply this ordinary least
square solution to the original problem
right remember we started out
was this data set our data set of x's
and y's is represented by these blue
dots and the idea was to recover the
trend between them
sort of the
statistics 101 right linear regression
and we we've just done this two ways one
way using gradient descent another way
using this analytical solution in both
cases the result is the same meaning
that you know we can basically recover
that underlying pattern in the data
uh if you're wondering like why am i
going crazy with gradient descent why do
i need all these iterations the short
answer is that if you look at the
analytical solution
uh this is actually relying on a very
computationally extensive expensive
rather
computationally expensive operation
known as matrix inversion so if you have
a data set that has a huge number of
features so think
uh on the order of tens of millions
billions of features
this matrix inversion is uh big o and
2.3
so somewhere in that range a naive
solution would be actually big o n cubed
so it's uh it's not feasible for large
data sets but the nice thing about
gradient descent is that it's scalable
you can actually scale it to many
features you can scale it actually
across many
nodes in a computing cluster
and although it gives you an approximate
answer it uh gradient descent works
quite well for modern neural networks
so the bottom line
is that both solutions did not exactly
recover that value of two remember we
said that we'll take x and multiply it
by 2
2 as the slope and then add some noise
well if you're wondering why the
solution even the analytical solution
did not return the value of 2 well it's
because
that noise
did not allow us to estimate the exact
slope we found an approximation but
that's the same thing that uh what the
gradient descent approach gave us right
same same idea we're looking for
estimate for approximation and in real
data sets you're going to have noise
anyway so
running this um expensive
computationally expensive ordinary
release
squares
approach
is not really getting you a lot of
benefit
so
uh
let's recap where we are so we started
out with a data set uh then we took that
data set and uh ran it through this
gradient descent
algorithm for 100 epochs remember 100
iterations or gradient descent
using the entire data set in this
iteration
and basically at every iteration we take
our model we make a guess
about the
uh whatever we're trying to predict
which is our y using that model we
figure out how good the guess is
compared the
compared to the actual values and then
we do these like quote unquote magical
operations
we zero out the gradient we compute the
backward loss so
i think
everything except these question mark
lines of code everything except six and
seven should sort of make sense and i
think line number nine will make more
sense after this next part of the
presentation
so what we're gonna do
is actually dive deeper into what does
it actually mean to zero out the
gradients why do you need that
what do you actually do when you back
propagate gradients
um
what does it mean how does this change
our model
so let's go ahead and do that and of
course if you have comments questions
just uh
uh have tons of ways of reaching me i
have my email there uh on the first
slide or if you want to post something
in the chat that works as well
okay
so i showed you that um you had to use
this
autograd library
automatic gradient library from pytorch
to use gradient descent
and behind the scenes
i torch autograph is using an algorithm
known as reverse mode accumulating
automatic differentiation
so it's quite a mouthful
and i think it obfuscates what actually
is going on
because this is a super important
algorithm uh in fact i read um a review
of some of the top algorithms invented
since 1970s and this is one of them and
the cool thing about it it was actually
invented by a masters student
in finland
so the algorithm itself is simple but
it's extremely powerful because it's
doing something
known as
chain rule
from calculus so if you've ever taken
calculus and did chain rule by hand this
algorithm is actually doing very very
complex chain rule applications
automatically so
there you go
now
if you're new to automatic
differentiation uh you need to know that
it's different from some of these other
techniques
you probably know
numeric differentiation from calculus
if you've ever done this approximation
if this brings back any painful memories
where you take some function like maybe
a linear function you add a little bit
of a this called epsilon like a small
step to it then you find difference
between x plus epsilon and f of x divide
by epsilon compute the limits that's
known as numeric differentiation
and
while it works well in college textbooks
in practice this is actually numerically
unstable
if you apply this directly to uh to
neural networks for instance and that
basically happens because as you know
the representation of floating point
numbers is using this um
mixed
mixed point
approximation and essentially these
floating point numbers don't actually
give you exact results and with the
numeric differentiation you accumulate a
lot of errors if you try to use them
directly
and this is also different the automatic
differentiation or auto def is different
from symbolic differentiation so if you
ever use packages like
mathematica they have something called
symbolic differentiation so you can give
them a function like y equals x squared
and it'll tell you hey the derivative of
y equals x squared uh respect to x is 2x
so that's great it gives you an
expression for the derivative the
problem is computationally symbolic
differentiation is more expensive so it
does give you a very general symbolic
expression for differentiation but
uh it does have quite a heavy cost
unlike auditive so autodiv is actually
order
of n and and here represents the number
of operations in your
basically in your loss function if you
apply auto div to machine learning it's
order of operations in your loss
calculations
and
this generally holds when you have this
loss calculation so this means when you
have a single output and many many
inputs
okay so here's the plan
i showed you the challenges with
understanding
the automatic differentiation feature of
pytorch
so there's a lot of this magical stuff
that you've seen like requires grad
you've seen the zeroing out of the
gradients it wasn't clear when to do
this you've seen the backward function
so what does that do exactly
i think the best way to explain
automatic differentiation is to actually
try to implement it yourself for a
simple case
and the great thing about automatic
differentiation is that it's
super easy in my mind at least to
implement it in python so let's go ahead
and do that let's actually create this
simple tensor a scalar
and this tensor is going to have the
following so let's have this tensor
we're going to emit it with a value so
we'll take a self and some value
and inside of that scalar we're going to
have the value of that scalar
and in addition to that we're going to
have a gradient
so this is where we're going to store
the gradient the derivative of the
scalar
and then i'm also going to introduce
the backward function so remember the
backward function is the one that
actually computes the gradients
something like a loss function
and for the time being in this default
implementation i'm going to make this a
no op
so this is going to be just a lambda
none okay
and this means you know if we call a
backward function it's just not going to
do anything by default of course that's
that's going to change
but in this simple implementation
it's just a no up
now let's implement the
overrides for the python add and
multiply methods so let's go ahead and
implement the addition of one scalar to
another so it's going to be a self and
have let's have it the other scalar and
then the result is straightforward
because the result is just a brand new
scalar where we take the value of this
scalar
and then add to it the value of the
other scalar
and then we
return the result
that's it so just take a moment to parse
that out and
i think that should be fairly
straightforward
let's do the same thing for multiply
so if we're multiplying two scalars we
also have ourselves
and some other value let's have a result
the result is going to be a brand new
scalar
and the result is just a product
of the self and the other scalar
so
we need to return this let's actually do
a sanity check just to make sure this
works because what we should be able to
do at this point is create a scalar
uh let's actually do this let's make
sure that all our scalars are floats
with integer values for the time being
so let's create a scalar let's add uh 2
and 3. so let's have a scalar of 2 plus
scalar 3 and i expect that this works it
does but the readability of the output
is terrible so let's change that let's
actually create a more readable output
let's create like a wrapper method so it
will give us a cell and let's return i'm
in python3 so let's return a formatted
string that
reports on the value
uh and the gradient
gradient is going to be cell.grad so for
the time being right there's no gradient
right because it's it's just zero we're
not doing any computation of derivatives
but you can see with that we can do
basic math and in fact um
this should already respect the
precedence rules for addition and
multiplication so let's do something
like
five
so if this works correctly we get 17
right because 3 times 5 15 plus 2 17 so
this works fine
and
i think
i think this is enough for now so let's
just uh
recap this
you got the scalar
just take a moment to appreciate that
because
in just a bit i'll pull up my first
track
where i'll use this class to
successfully compute a derivative
you're probably looking at it like carl
how can this computer derivative
well i didn't say can compute any
derivative it can compute a very simple
derivative
and here's how it's going to work
let's create our x
and remember autodev computes
derivatives at specific points of a
function
so in this case i'm going to use scalar
2.
and guess what
that works no surprise there
and i told you that i can compute
derivatives well i can compute it but
for this very trivial function
y equals x
so i want you to start putting your um
calculus hats on for a moment just think
about this and think about what this
looks like right so essentially if you
think about this function it's that
straight line
uh going exactly through the center of
the origin
uh y equals x
so
this is what we're going to use to
compute our first gradient of the first
derivative
uh in this session so here's how you're
going to do this
remember that we're using floating point
values so that's cool
let's do the first thing remember
zeroing out the gradients i said that
that's important
well this is important because
going forward
this will not always be the case
if you think about our scalar
by default a brand new scalar always has
x dot grad equals zero but remember that
we actually want to run this in uh
multiple epochs and multiple iterations
of gradient descent so
this can actually change
iteration to iteration
so this is one of the first reasons why
we actually set it to zero so okay so
let's say it has to be zero now here's
the next thing that we're going to set
and that's going to be the y gradient
and this is probably where you're
thinking hey uh this doesn't make a lot
of sense like why are we setting
the y gradient and why did you pick
number one for the y gradient we're
trying to figure out
how does changing x translate into
changing the y right what's the
relationship between them we're trying
to differentiate that function y equals
x so where did this number one come from
well if you think about it just
conceptually what we're saying is that y
dot grad
is the rate of change that change in y
has to itself so this is basically if
you want to think of it in um calculus
terms is d y d y
and what do you what do you get if you
divide something by itself
well that's uh that's a one
so that's what we got to to a value one
here
okay so hopefully uh you're buying into
this so far
now i'm actually going to go ahead and
differentiate
so let's uh let's call our backwards
method so remember we said we're going
to back propagate those gradients from y
back to x
so that's what we're figuring out so
let's do that back propagation
and confirm that after back propagating
the value of x
radiant change so in other words we're
able to find out what is the derivative
d y d x
and
x dot grad is actually storing that
value
so notice we started with zero and now x
dot grad is a one
okay
so
uh
here i want you to think about this for
a moment and if you're saying hey carl
that looks like cheating
i can see where you're coming from
the thing is
remember our definition of y
y is just x
so when we said y dot grad equals one
we've basically overwritten this line of
code so we changed what what is the
value of x
so where's the magic well i told you
this implementation actually computes
gradients for a very simple function
it does give you the right answer if you
have a function uh y equals x
this implementation works correctly the
backward is a no up
uh but this does correctly compute the
uh dydx
so
if this is unsatisfying let's try a more
complex example you'll see that actually
it's fairly straightforward to change
this
and get a
more interesting function to work with
and still get cool answers
so let's actually implement this
backward support in the add function
let's go back into our scalar remember
our 13 line code scaler
and let's add
part of the implementation that will
allow us to compute
back propagation of the gradient for
more complex functions so notice that
when we are adding two scalars right now
we're not computing anything related to
a back problem so let's change that
let's do this
first of all let's define what it means
to compute
compute the gradients so define this
backward function
in this backward function uh actually
what i'll do i'll assign it to the
resulting gradient
so notice that here i'm saying that the
result the backward function
is the implementation of whatever
backward function i'll put in here
so what is that implementation going to
be
well we're adding two scalars we need to
back propagate the gradients well we
need to be able to
use
the gradient of the result
to set the gradient for
self
remember this is going to be the
resulting gradient and we need to set
the gradient for the self and for the
other
scalar because that's
that's what it means to send the
gradient backwards right from the result
back to whatever scalars were used as
inputs
and this is where the accumulating part
of this algorithm comes in so notice
that uh if we're sending that result
what we need to be able to uh to define
is a scenario where
both
this scalar and this scalar are the same
so what we need to be able to do is
accumulate these gradients and that's
exactly what's going on here so plus
equals is the accumulating part for the
gradients and notice how we're going to
define it
if you think about computation of the
gradients let's say you have a function
that looks like this right so x is one
scalar z is another scalar and you know
that your y is going to have that
gradient of one right d y d y we said
it's going to have the value of one
and we're asking okay
what is the
uh
what is the gradient d y d x
again here you need to think a little
bit to calculus and basically what this
means d y d x this means that all things
being equal
if you make a small change to x how does
this translate into a change to y
and the all things being equal part
means that z doesn't change z stays the
same so any changes to x are translated
directly into changes to y
d is not carrying any changes at all so
what this means is that the gradient of
the cell vector of this vector is just
the same thing as the gradient of the
output
so they're the same gradient
and the same thing is true for the other
gradient we want to accumulate
and then we just want to take the value
from the result
now the last thing you have to do if you
want to implement this kind of
automatic differentiation is actually
called backward recursively because what
happens is that you can actually um
you need to be able to com combine many
of these sensors together and send this
backward computation the sending of the
gradient
um back across many many scalars so the
way that you do this is just recursively
called self.backward
and then you need to also be able to do
uh this on the other scaler as well
so you call self.backward other that
backward and
that's it
that's all it takes
you know that the gradient is just the
gradient of the result same thing here
so you've back propagated the result
to the two
initial tensors that we use to compute
the result
you uh hold the backward recursively
which in a very simple case is just a no
up
you assigned the backward to the result
you returned it and this is it that's
all that it takes to actually add back
propagation to a function
that adds multiple scalars so for
example
let's start with a very simple example
y equals x plus x
if you think about this again uh think
high school
uh calculus college calculus this is y
equals 2x
same thing right we're just adding the
addition here using the addition to
define the function
so that's that's all that it takes to
find a function
and uh think about back propagating
gradients basically you'll create a new
tensor right y is just this new scalar
tensor that has two axes as inputs and
you want to back propagate that y
gradient to these input tensors which
just happen to be the same
um
same scalar so let's say say that this
is scalar
value three
this is our y and then let's let's run
the backwards pass and the backwards
pass is exactly the same as before so
remember zero out the gradient
y gradient remember it has to be one
let's use floating point numbers here
uh let's go ahead and run the backward
pass so y dot backward so remember here
y dot backward will run on the scalar
that is produced by adding two of these
axes together
and let's find out what we get well here
i can tell you it's not going to be 3
because remember the function that we're
trying for is
2 times x but i can tell you that now if
you compute this you should get the
value of 2
which
is the case
so notice what happened here you figured
out how does the change
back propagate from y
because the change of one
essentially was computed by
uh perspective changes to x's
essentially every small change in x if
twice the change to the y
and that's uh you know you can keep
expanding this so let's change to y
equals three times x
uh run the back propagation find out the
gradient
no surprise there you get d y d x equals
three
all right
so let's try to make this um
more complex
let's see what it would take to actually
do this kind of a
backward propagation compute in the
multiplication function so let's do this
let's take the uh scalar class that we
just defined
copy and paste it into the
multiplication function actually what
i'll do is move this around slightly so
it's closer to the top of the
class definition
and then let's go ahead and
update the definition of the
backward function for multiplication as
well so let's define the backward
function
and let's not forget that in the result
this is the function that we should be
using to compute the back propagation
now the cool thing about this is that
the logic
is pretty much the same so
what is the gradient
for the self
scalar so now this one that was used as
part of the input to the result
well we know the gradient for the result
right it's going in the opposite
direction it's going from y back to the
x
so
it's going to depend on the result
so result gradient
has to be in there but the thing is
here if you think about the relationship
between the x and the y remember how i
said that when you're computing the
gradients the question is d y d x right
what is the relationship between the
changes of y and changes to x
all other things being equal
well the other
tensor
just stays constant right if you're
computing the change relative to x the
other tensor is just some constant
and that's exactly what we need to put
in here so in other words the other
tensor's value
is that constant that multiplying the
the gradient and that's how we're
accumulating the gradient for the first
input tensor and the same thing for the
second dimple tensor because
in this case
the other
tensor's value is the constant
and we multiply that by the resulting
gradient
and finally the last thing we need to do
so we don't forget how to
back propagate this we need to call
salva backward
and other dot backwards so we get that
recursive call to back propagate the
gradients to the other tensors
that's pretty much it so
i'll leave this here for a moment
and then let's go ahead and run this
so here's our new um
implementation let's try it like we did
before let's try it with a very simple
scalar first so let's say we have the
scalar with a value of 4
and let's try a simple function
where we just multiply
x's three times
like this so we have x cubed
y equals x cubed so what this means is
that now if we run the
back propagation so remember initialize
our gradients to zero
set the output gradient
do one
and then finally do the back propagation
so let's do y backward
or back propagate
radians
2x
and find out what x should be so here if
you think about it right gradient of x
since
we have x cubed
or
the value of x equals 4 this means that
we have uh
3x squared so for value of 4 x squared
is 16 and 3 times 16 gives you 48.
so again very simple implementation
something clearly obvious
in terms of how we're getting this in
the implementation of the backward
function but
it gives you the exact value
and in fact this scales to more complex
functions because now we can do even
things like
plus x plus x so the entire function
looks like y
x cubed plus two x
uh we can back propagate that using the
same code
and now of course the gradient gets
updated to the right value because the
analytical solution to this updated
function which is x cubed plus
2x uh if you try to solve that
analytically you get 3x squared plus 2.
so we already know that 3x squared gives
you 48 plus 2 gives you 50. so that's
the uh that's the calculation of the
gradient
all right and now
you basically have a working tensor
which is a rank zero tensor but it works
so let's actually uh before the end of
this session
take this implementation that we just
created
this very very simple implementation of
autodiff
and apply it again to linear regression
so let's do the following
let's again create a brand new model
our remember our random parameter let's
initialize it to
some random value remember from
negative one to one
again i'll use that uniform
so a uniform method
passing w we want the uniform
probability between negative one and one
uh let's take a look at that w so here's
the pi torch tensor remember it still
requires gradient but instead of using
that pi torch tensor i what i want to
explain is that we want to use the
scalar
uh
for w
and now i can actually explain to you
what this requires grab actually means
so by default when you create tensors in
pytorch they actually are missing that
dot grad
um
that grad attribute remember in our
scalar we have a dot grad
well guess what if you have dot grad
this basically doubles the amount of
memory that you need to store for every
scalar you need to sort the value right
the remember the dot val property and
then on top of that you need to store
dot grad
so
if you have a lot of tensors that have
data in them like for example if you're
loading up tensors of color images like
huge images maybe tens of megs and
you're loading a collection with um
millions of them
that'll
use up a lot of space so that's why by
default pi torch actually doesn't
include this property with a gradient
and the only way to enable it in pi
torch is that when you create a brand
new tensor is that you need to set this
requires grad true but in our case with
our simple python-based scalar
implementation we don't need to worry
about it we just create a scalar and the
way that we're going to create it is
just by taking
this random value the negative zero five
nine six four that we just got
and uh
we'll shove that directly into our
scalar so if you're wondering about
these uh
properties and methods the dot data is
basically pulling in this data value the
floating point number
from the tensor and item actually
returns it back so now
we have the scalar
with this randomly generated value and
let me actually shove it into that same
uh
variable w
so this is going to be our new model
value
so now i'm going to actually create some
linear regression data so let's actually
create uh
data similar to the ones that we used
before
so i'll create
in this case a list of scalars so let's
say x now is going to be a list of
scalars
and i'll create these scalars
by doing
a python range so let's do i for
i in range let's say it's going to be in
the range from
negative 50 to 50 and then what i'd like
to do is actually let's multiply each
one of them by 0.1 so we have a 100
values that are in the increments of 0.1
so we'll use this as a feature values
for the linear regression right so i'll
just change this to slice the first few
elements for readability but now what
you have here is some sample data that
you can use for linear regression
except you're missing the y values and
for y
let's keep this simple without any noise
this time if you want to
uh and i'll explain why shortly but
basically let's create y
by
uh setting the values of x so we'll use
x sub i
multiplied by two
remember the slope for our line is two
and this is going to be four i in
range land
of x so basically iterating for every
element of x and every y is going to be
twice x sub one now there's one thing
that's a problem here notice that we're
just doing this multiplication we're not
actually creating scalars
and for us to be able to do this linear
regression with simple
tensors we need to package them as
scalars so let's actually do that
so now x is a scalar we need to make
this a scalar so we can multiply
correctly so now we have scalar times a
scalar that's good
let's confirm that's the case
uh
we run this one
we have scalars here
scalars in y
and now you have your data for linear
regression
so uh let's see if this very very simple
implementation of uh autodiv in pure
python can actually solve linear
regression
so again let's go ahead and implement
that function that gives us guesses it
computes the forward so it takes the x
and the w let's go ahead and do that
guess so how do we do that we need to
compute the error how do we compute the
error well remember we need to find the
difference between the
actual values and the predicted values
i'm sorry the let's do the predictions
first so the forward function is going
to generate the predictions how do we
generate the predictions it's going to
be just x times w right so we take the w
scalar we multiply it by x sub i
uh for i in range
of x
and that's uh that's what we returned so
this forward function now gives us
predictions for the inputs and you can
confirm that this works
pass and the w and x and you can see
that this is giving you initial guesses
off of that random w remember we used
that random value for w
to generate these guesses this is what
they are so the whole idea is to take
these guesses
measure how good these guesses are using
a mean squared error
and then improve so now we have all the
tools that we need to do that with
exception of the mean squared error
calculation so let's implement that
function so this function will take the
our scalars for y and y predictions
and now we need to compute the error so
how do we compute the error we need to
take the uh y scalars
and then find the difference between y
and y predictions right
and this is going to be for i
in
range lan
y
and these are going to have to be
y sub prediction
this is y
and this gives you the calculation of
the error with one exception remember
that we never actually implemented the
plus or the minus sign for our scalars
let's actually go ahead and do that
so uh instead of
just doing a minus we can always do a
plus
and then what we need to do is do a
scalar
which is going to be negative one
multiplied by
uh the prediction
so this will give you the negative y
prediction we add that to y sub uh y sub
i
and this will give you the error
so that's the error let's find the mean
squared error the mean squared error is
uh
is two things right if we need to find
the mean that means that we need to be
able to take
a one divided by number of elements
in y so this will give us the first
scalar
and we need to multiply that by the sum
of all the uh scalars that we have in
the errors right we're finding the mean
of this error squared
now
uh one thing that i haven't done yet is
actually square the air so let's let's
square the air
let's do uh error i
times error i
or i in range
error
so
sc is the squared error
and then finally to compute the sum of
these squared errors let's do a sum of
sc and we need to give a starter value
because it needs to be a scalar right
we're going to try to add the first
element here to a zero
but that zero has to be a scalar of zero
so we can use a built-in python function
called sum
this will give us the sum of the squared
errors
we multiply that by one divided over
[Music]
the number of errors
if you prefer we can do this
some of the errors and this will give us
the mean square error which actually is
what we want to return
so let's go ahead and return that mean
squared error confirm that this works
so msc of y and let's do a predictions
of
these y's
confirm
and it doesn't want to multiply
something so let's see
uh it doesn't want to multiply the x
times the
x sub i let me see which one it is this
is in the forward method so the part
that failed was in the forward
not anywhere else
what we need to be able to pass in here
is the
correct implementation of the fourth
method
so the bug that i had is that i passed
in y instead of w
so now we pass in the w
these generate the guesses the
predictions for what the y's are
this uh these are the actual values and
the msc gives you our new homegrown
implementation of a scalar tensor
with the calculation of the um of the
value of the mean squared error so
that's pretty much it
now the only thing that we need is
around that same gradient descent
so let's do that
let's actually re-implement gradient
descent using uh the approach that
we've had before so let's do
uh same number of epochs just so you can
see it's doing pretty much the same
thing for uh in range epochs
so gradient descent for epochs
we need to create the predictions
so forward of x and w
now we need to be able to compute our
loss using those predictions so let's
compute the loss using the mean squared
error function
there we go and now we need to do all
that same magic that we did before
except we're going to do it with our
scalar class so let's figure out what
we're doing
so why are we setting the w grad
to zero so remember before you had to
zero out the gradients well now you
should be able to say why you need this
line of code remember in your
calculation of the backward function
you're going to accumulate gradients to
w
so which which means that every time you
run this epoch this iteration of
gradient descent the gradients are going
to accumulate they're going to keep
adding into w gram but for every epoch
of gradient descent you need to compute
the gradients from scratch you need to
find a brand new gradient because w is
going to change right
so that's why we're actually using this
uh
zeroing out of the gradient for our
model
if you use pytorch in pi torch
oftentimes you'll use an optimizer
zero grad
as the alternative to this but it's
doing exactly the same thing basically
optimizes your grab iterates from all
the model parameters in your model that
needs to be
zeroed out and it's basically setting
them to
none which is the pi torch equivalent or
gradient zero
now we also need to do the loss
equals one so remember this is our
d y d y equals one idea we're saying
what the gradient of the output function
should be and of course
from uh discussion earlier you know it's
one because it's a ratio of a change
with a cell well in case of uh pie torch
so in ply torch whenever you call the
backward method this actually sets the
output gradient to one automatically
so
sets uh one automatically
but you can change that so in fact if
you look at the definition of the tensor
backward method in pytorch it'll tell
you that behind the scenes you can
change how to set the gradient for the
output if you want to
this gets a little bit technical as to
why would you want to do this
but if you want to change the output
gradient you can
finally remember that we need to
actually run the back propagation so at
this point if you run lost backdrop
or loss backward this actually runs this
implementation of backward function that
you've just seen moments ago we have
very simple scalar of course now the
loss function is way more complex than
any of those functions that we use right
we're multiplying a lot of these data
points together we're
computing the means we're computing the
squared errors etc so the function is a
lot more complex in terms of the number
of the gradients
but the computation for those gradients
is super simple is like four lines of
code
for that self.grad and other.grad
function so now we've computed the
gradients which means that w dot grad
now has the gradient or our loss
function and this means that you can
actually do the following let's go ahead
and change the value of w
by learning rate times
w dot red so we're taking the gradient
descent step one w in the direction
opposite of the gradient which is the
definition of gradient descent
and let's go ahead and run that and find
out what we get back
so this is our gradient descent
and
hey no bugs so this perfectly recovered
the value that i just used to actually
create the values of x
and um
and y
if you recall
the initial data came in
these scalars
sampling the first five
values out of each one of them
so these are the data values that our
machine learning algorithm used
radiant descent algorithm and we
perfectly recovered
the slope that i set of two
uh using gradient descent and
using your scalar implementation
so that's that's pretty much it and now
you can say hey
i know
at which point in the loop to actually
set the gradient to zero because uh
what if you set it to zero here well
doesn't really matter because you don't
call the the backward function up until
this point you want to call the gradient
zero in this case sure why not doesn't
really change things or as many people
actually do in practice you can set the
gradient to zero after
you update
update the value of the model so in fact
in pytorch it's very common to do
this step of the optimizer so in pytorch
this would be optimizer
dot step
and then
optimizer.0grad
to zero out the gradient but of course
if you want to there's nothing changing
if you do the same operation in the
beginning of the loop in fact they're
equivalent right
so uh hopefully this gives you a little
bit of an insight into
inner workings of automated
differentiation it's a super powerful
algorithm as i said earlier uh it was
called one of the top
scientific computing algorithms invented
since 1970s
i know that if you
are going to be going to college in the
next few years it's probably going to be
part of the curriculum so definitely
something you need to know about if you
are planning on becoming a machine
learning practitioner
but you can see that this is fairly
straightforward to implement for simple
functions like addition and
multiplication and of course in pytorch
what happens is that
the pi torch team implemented
the
automated differentiation not just for
additional multiplication but also for
more sophisticated functions like
relu for instance rectified linear unit
which is commonly used in
machine learning and others
so here uh i'm gonna stop uh just gonna
type out a few more of these links into
the chat so some of these links i've
already posted so
here's the link to the exercise that i
just worked on
uh if you want to link to a solution
it's the
uh
this this link as i recall
there we go
productive solution
the both of these should work the
solution of course already has the code
you need and finally
if you want to follow
some of the changes that i'm posting
about machine learning stuff that i do
or if you're interested in getting a
copy of this recording what i'll do is
actually post the link
to the recording to the folks who sign
up or check in using this form so this
is how i can actually get your
information and send you a link to the
recording
and that's pretty much it pretty much
everything i wanted to cover so in this
session you've seen uh
you've seen a lot
if you've never used pytorch uh this is
really a deep dive into what's going on
with spy torch behind the scenes
i showed you an example of a very simple
tensor scaler and then showed you how
you can actually implement
key features of automated
differentiation for pi torch yourself
and you've seen that if you implemented
yourself you can even do things like
linear regression
with this
small implementation of your automatic
differentiation algorithm
and this gives you insights into when
and how you can use these
high torch automatic differentiation app
programming interfaces and when and how
you should use these operations like
optimizer xerograd optimizer step and
others
and why that sequence matters behind the
scenes
so hopefully next time if you're using
pytorch or if you're planning on using
pytorch uh code from my book uh you're
not guessing or you're not treating
pytorch shadow grad is magic instead you
know exactly what's happening behind the
scenes and how it's actually uh
computing the chain rule of calculus for
you
uh using a fairly simple
uh sequence of these kinds of recursive
calls
so with that what i'd like to do is say
huge thank you to all of you
i've post up posted up a link to the
serverless machine learning book
so if you want to learn more about
pytorch more about how to actually use
pytorch as a machine learning
practitioner
staying productive and developing your
machine learning models without getting
overwhelmed with concerns of putting
your machine learning model into
operations babysitting your machine
learning model when it's running in a
cloud definitely check out the book you
can learn a lot about
preparing your data you can learn about
building machine learning models with
pytorch on aws and if you want to use
the discount code there in the bottom
right hand corner
i'll
post that as well so the discount code
that i listed
is going to uh
give you 40 off the list price of the
book
so with that
again huge thank you and
stay in touch i gave you my contact
information and i wish you all the best
in learning about
data science
machine learning and software
development